kenno health who is sponsoring this
segment has been expanding in the las
vegas area to better serve the community
here to tell us more is reuben kiewen
and lana brooks welcome you too hi
thanks for having us it's great to see
you guys so what are some of the
programs that you guys offer so kenneth
health is a primary care clinic we offer
primary care we offer physiotherapy
which is management of pain and then we
also offer healthy art program which is
the program that i'm
in charge of so tell us more about that
program there so a healthy heart program
is a preventive cardiology program that
really focuses on taking a patient's
health history and making an assessment
and uh taking their risk factors and
then putting into a plan to prevent them
from having a heart attack or stroke in
the next 10 years so you guys you guys
go deep when it comes to a patient's
history you learn more about them to
give them the ultimate care yep we do
some studies and um look at their labs
health history medications are on and go
from there and you're ever expanding
ever growing room we have a big grand
opening taking place this weekend we do
so we want to invite everybody to the
grand opening of our eighth clinic in
las vegas we already have eight um and
it's going to take place at 3880
west lake mead boulevard okay so near
the texas and fiesta station uh and for
those of you who want to know more about
condo health visit connorhealth.com
uh you know lana talks about the
programs also the personal touch you
know the doctors that we have the nurse
practitioners their staff they know your
story they know your family uh you feel
at home when you go to connell health so
what's the place at the grand opening
this weekend so we're going to be having
all kinds of uh entertainment music
we're going to have food
and also we're going to have an
opportunity to give tours for anyone
who's interested in finding out a little
bit about how our clinics look and what
we have to offer
you guys cover everything you truly do
because it's healthcare but also do you
have pharmacy needs as well
uh yeah so all across the country so we
have over 150 clinics all across the
country here in nevada we're in the
process of getting the the pharmacy uh
but in those eight clinics right now
that we have we have uh primary care for
seniors we have the physiotherapy
programs the healthy hearts and uh any
other type of primary care needs that
our seniors need and how is when it
comes to care for seniors i mean this
this is a growing honesty industry but
it is continuing to to growing and
expand even larger which is fantastic
for you guys opening up more clinics
yeah
uh the the population is growing as you
spoke lady boomers are coming up and
they're needing a lot of care and
prevention is the main thing that we
focus on at ken ohio i love it so the
grand opening is tomorrow thank you so
much for joining us we appreciate it
congratulations on the success and the
great continued growth as well thank you
keno health is opening their new clinic
tomorrow 3880 west lake mead boulevard
you can reach them at
702-848-2875 or visit kenohealth.com